bird snap will be an iPhone app in the
App Store and it also is a site bird
snap comm and so if you go to that site
what you'll see is you'll see 500 of the
most common North American bird species
accompanied with the bird songs and then
pictures of the birds out in in wild
it's a really exciting time to be
working in computer vision and machine
learning and one of the things that's
changed since when I sort of started
working in this area is the explosion in
images so there are just so many photos
that people are taking that there's this
real need to kind of figure out
automatically what's happening within
those photos so you can do things like
search through photo collections or
organize photo collections or kind of
figure out what's there what it is that
you're looking at and that's sort of the
some of the stuff that we do for Leisha
happen and bird snap so when we start
designing the bird snap app we wanted to
do something that we thought was very
different from what had been done before
we wanted to see whether or not we could
use computer vision and machine learning
technology to automatically generate a
field guide so in other words field guys
are usually constructed by hand where
people go in and they write all the text
and they decide how they're going to
layout the pages and they decide on sort
of what order the species are going to
be shown in and what we wanted to do is
to see whether or not we could use this
technology to automatically lay this out
in such a way that we could almost teach
people how to recognize different
species of birds so to do visual
recognition either with the the app or
the website you you take a picture when
you're using the app you would take the
picture directly with your phone or if
you're using the website you may have a
nice camera and you've taken the picture
and you've downloaded it to your
computer but in either case the image is
uploaded to our servers and we also ask
the user to either tap or click on the
head and the tail of the
and then our algorithms find all the
different parts of the bird the beak the
eye the wings the the legs the tail and
extract features from those different
parts of the bird that then the machine
learning algorithm is used to recognize
the species so the first thing is that
is that we automatically figure out
visually similar species so that the
user can kind of nail down what species
they're looking at the second thing that
we do is we give in visually similar
species we can show automatically where
they should look on the bird to
differentiate them so if one bird has a
yellow beak and the other has a black
beak we'll highlight that and this is
done fully automatically there's there's
no user in the loop right our algorithms
figure this out automatically and then
the third thing that we do as part of
the visual recognition is we analyze
sightings data to figure out what the
likelihood is that a particular species
is at a place in the United States on a
particular date and we use this to
better the recognition algorithms so for
instance we know what all the bird
species are in New York today and we
know what all the bird species will be
in say San Francisco in December next
year here's the birds neck website and
in terms of being location aware right
now it's it's showing all the birds of
the United States so this is the full
set of 500 birds around a wheel here you
can you can scroll through them and look
at their images and actually
you can also hear them it's sort of the
golden age we've never had this sort of
data and we've never had this sort of
demand to be able to take this
incredible collection these trillions of
images that are being acquired and to be
able to use technology computer vision
and machine learning to organize this
data in some useful way